you know when i talked to some
entrepreneurs i said how's business they
say oh i'm surviving and i'm a survivor
i'm survivor i'm doing good but i'm
surviving you know you know this whole
thing about i'm surviving you know it's
okay how's business i was like you know
how it is man we're surviving i'm a
survivor man that's what i am and i'm
like
i don't know if i want to be a survivor
for the rest of my life can you imagine
if your entire life you're trying to
survive from drowning in the middle of
the ocean what's life like if you're
constantly just trying to survive the
whole idea is if you're constantly
as an entrepreneur surviving you're
probably better off being an employee
than an entrepreneur here's why listen
the whole concept about like even when
beyonce came up with the song i'm a
survivor not she didn't come up with a
song destiny's jobs when they had the
song i'm a survivor it was in 2001. she
was born in 81 she was 20 years old
right maybe at that time she was trying
to survive the industry today she's
worth a half a billion dollars if not
more right she took it to a whole
different level
the whole thing is about constantly
thriving with the period where you're
surviving has got to be limited maybe
one year two years three years five
years i'm speaking to miles gibrani
yesterday
comedian and i said give me the business
model of comedians he says it's very
simple he said perform three times a day
you know he said yeah perform three to
five times a day
write every single day but three to five
times a day so if it's a three minute
skit you know five minutes it doesn't
matter every day try to do three to five
and write every single day right he says
the game of the comedian if you look at
comedy you kind of start you know
exploding in your 30s you don't
typically see guys in their 20s even he
says you know
what's his name uh chappelle started at
14 he excelled at 23. that's still a
nine-year run rate right
in every business i understand surviving
for a year two years three years five
years my number is five years in the
world of business for five years it's
gonna be a little bit annoying it's
gonna be a little bit challenging but if
you've been doing the surviving game for
20 years you're doing something wrong
just be very honest with you either your
habits suck either the moment you make
some money you spend all of it either
every single time you have some momentum
you get cocky there is something that's
happening that's causing you to
constantly stay in the survival mode it
could be a part of your identity you
don't think you're worth the next level
money you don't want to put the effort
the moment you start succeeding thinking
it's going to happen by itself and you
no longer need to put the work that got
you to start creating some momentum but
there's got to be something there so
either if you don't want to pay the
price go be an employee go be an
entrepreneur entrepreneur but if you do
want to be an entrepreneur and you do
want to go out there and do something
big stop being in the survival mode
graduate life is about graduating
certain phases in life and one of the
things you got to graduate is being a
survivor instead being a thriver having
said that i got a video for you it's
called seven habits of highly effective
entrepreneurs if you've never watched it
click over here to watch it and if
you're committed to graduating the
survivor mode and being a thriver smash
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
take care everybody
[Music]